e l'ora di allenarmi a chiamare la
vostra scopo alzatevi in piedi è salvata
non essere vite su grazie giù giù
ogni volta che io inizio una serie no
devo capire se continuarla in base ai
vostri gusti se vi è piaciuto no quindi
non so se continuare la serie d arrivo
ok mi sa che facciamo un altro episodio
siccome dipenderà come andrà anche
questo episodio se volete che la serie
continui
riguardatevi questo video tre volte
purtroppo ragazzi ho perso un pezzettino
di registrazione vi racconto cosa è
successo così capito come sono arrivato
fin lì logicamente merula che questa
lurida sudicia schifosa brava ragazza mi
ha chiuso nell'armadio veramente e
dentro l'armadio c'è il tranello del
diavolo quindi io devo liberarmi dal
tranello e gli auguro questo è quello
che è successo buona visione
sfuggì al tranello del diavolo vai
maledizione sfuggì a sottrarre allo del
diavolo è sì però su mettermi a bada la
macarena le cuffie respingi vai tranello
schifoso vai axwell ingrosso s'è
liberato l'uomo venne come ho fatto a
metterlo dentro lo sgabuzzino con la
merula per una schifosa
porca vacca quanto difficile strappa i
dolci energia salita ogni 4 minuti
aspettare la tua energia si carichi
oppure compra altri 30 o più energia ma
fate schifo non si compra la magia dai
malizia ho dovuto spendere 3 euro per
liberarmi dal tranello del diavolo tieni
i soldi liberami continua così lorenzo
che non li aver sentito qualcuno chiese
i fili grazie datemi i soldi oggetti
sono sbloccato degli oggetti
cosa succede lì dentro fuori di qui che
hagrid aera grido effettivamente per
tutti gargoyle tasso frasso allontanati
da quel tranello del diavolo la stai
spaventano ma sei scemo c'è un cosa che
vi sta strangolando una granata
ammazzerei io la sto spaventando usciamo
di qui grande hagrid sembra amico delle
bestie ed etiche cose schifose tipo
pietro io sono lorenzo studi ma tu sei
quello che tu sei quello che ne parlano
tutti forse siete davvero dei
combinaguai nella tua famiglia come ci
sei finito qui lo re
una di sempreverde nel primo anno merula
sneijder c'è chi si guada è stata lei
e adesso cosa fa
vendicati gliela farò pagare per aver
cercato di uccidermi capisco che ti
senti così ma la vendetta di solito non
funziona per nessuno forse ci deve
ripensare senti non sono harry potter
io faccio i culi mi sa che devi fare
anche qualcosa per quel mantello il
tranello del diavolo ti ha beccato
proprio in pieno grazie a grid e spero
di rivederti di nuovo ma certo che mi
rive di lorenzo ma ora è meglio che te
ne torni in un altro sarà comune va bene
grazie a grid è stato bellissimo ma devo
ritornare alla tipa a dirle che
effettivamente non ci hanno ridato i
punti della casa che era stata merula
slide a chiudermi come sarà contenta di
saperlo
ciao jane sono quasi morto per diana
cosa è successo tutto mantello sono
stati in tre parti mentre nel diavolo ma
cosa succede tratta di questa ragazza è
di sicura non ci piacciamo credo si
senta minacciata da me e credo non
sopporti il fatto che sono l'unico del
primo anno che l'abbia affrontata e
presumo che anche stavolta tu non abbia
prove c'è solo un [ __ ] mantello
bucato come tua sorella
vai a metterti un mantello nuovo anzi
scegli qual cosa indossare al di fuori
dell'orario di lezione famiglia del re
commenti cosa dove indossa posso
cambiare ma veramente cos'è ma che
brutto ma no dai 20.000 di villa che
schifo poi davvero applicare questa
modifica lorenzo suo insieme
ho indossato di vestiti nuovi sono
contenti vediamo come ti stanno nomi
guardare faccio schifo sembra uscito
dagli anni 40 che si va molto meglio
cosa non mai visto nessuno gira la dog
marx così farei meglio a sbrigarsi ad
andare alla prima lezione di volo è una
vera lezione di volo no dai è verificata
venisse trovi il modo di guadagnare
punti della casa mentre sei ok posso
andare alle elezioni di volo così
vestito come troglodita va bene il campo
e posso andare voi che bello la bufera
va bene o salve campo d'allenamento vai
a lezioni di volo
benvenuti alla prima lezione di volo
sono vada ma un vengo da una famiglia di
barney è l'idea di volare su una scopa
mi terrorizza ti capisco zio anche io
mica gray addosso però sempre meglio una
scopa in volo che una scopa nel q1 penso
di poter andare avanti così lorenzo puoi
farcela ben dai promettimi di prendermi
se dovessi cadere se sì ti prendo io non
vedi che muscoli che ciò come faccio
come si fa lula si vabbè quale un
fenomeno non vale perdete la
concentrazione anche per un secondo e
finirete per cadere molto mare
ascoltatemi codice c'è il tasto
concentrati quanto mi sarebbe servito a
scuola davvero tocca i cerchi quando
sono nella stessa dimensione
ok va bene posso andare avanti mi fai
volare sulla scopa non mi fai fare tipo
su
discuti dei capelli ma siete scemi
discuti delle scosse ti piace la mia
scopa
ok perfetto dammi una gemma che non ho
ben capito cosa servano 89 ciccio game
vediamo se avete apprezzato attenzione
chi sa rispondere a questa domanda io
prof
dove si svolgono le lezioni di volo a
casa di pietro mentre lui fa i video che
magari escono meglio campo di quidditch
cortile della torre dell'orologio campo
d'allenamento con le lezioni di volo
che cazzo ne so non nel campo da qui
dice perché li giocano a 15 cortile
della torre dell'orologio campo di
allenamento
insomma si grande madonna il fenomeno
grazie grazie a tutti grazie un vero
potter ed come si fa ma io non volevo
fare su coppa delle case a chi fa vedere
come siamo messi
grande siamo ultimi e grandissimi
vinsero a chiamare la vostra scopa
giovanna la chiamo che senso ha chiamare
la scopa scusa cosa fanno questi sono
scemi da dover uccidere la mia scopa
devo disegnare delle delle pop e per
farlo
un attimo madonna separa di allenarvi a
chiamare la vostra scopo alzatevi in
piedi è salvata non essere di te su
grazie giù giù
fai una domanda prof come si dice su ok
ho preso una stella bonus vai prendi
soldi i soldi adesso devo carasco dire
su ora ostuni è il momento di vedere
come chiami la tua scopo trina vieni so
che prendo su su magnifico ma dove che
schifo
che bello se non avessero scritto su
whatsapp grazie alice di mondadori
comprate the cage il mio libro che si
faccia anche un po di pubblicità mio
libro così va dice contenta anch'io sono
pronti e comprate le cage che è più
belle di sta roba qua scritta da come
rolling the cage grazie per l'aiuto
lorenzo prego ho fatto niente
credo che tu abbia scelto un ottimo
insegnante coppa grazie grazie prof
ostuni
sembra che tu abbia un talento naturale
per aiutare i compagni di classe a
superare nelle loro paure
se io ho paura dei ragni
10 punti a tasso frase o li ho
recuperati 10 punti volevo parlare
comunque con roma non abbiamo passate
tante ma credo che lui ne risente più di
me
chiedigli ago biglie prego biglie
progressi evoca la scopa vai a lezioni
di volo l'ho fatto ma io volevo fare su
a cagare
grazie madama boom per le sue lezioni di
scopa andiamo avanti grazie cortile
stato bello ovunque mi piace fare ho
chiesto deficiente ma cos'è a2 corvo
nero che si stanno esercitando 1
depressissimo è stato freddo nato ieri
le due tipi che parlano di come
funzionare meglio sala grande eccomi io
che sono vestito malissimo infermeria
potrà entrare nell'anno 2 se ti fai male
prima del secondo anno sei morto
scalinata principale puoi entrare nella
ue salire le scale solo al quinto anno
prima devi usare l'ascensore che non c'è
cortile a cortile possa andare si
incontra rowan non lo vedo da una vita
da quando ci hanno colpiti con tranello
del diavolo pensate
passiamo sempre dei bei momenti insieme
perché non lo vedo più ciao rowan grazie
all'invito rowan dopo tutto quello che è
successo con merula happy town mi ci
voleva una pausa non mi dice niente se
il mio bel vestito aspetterebbe ha
giocato a gobbi llama così bottiglie un
po come il gioco delle biglie di barney
eccetto che ogni volta che si fa appunto
il perdente riceve uno spruzzo in faccia
ok uno spruzzo di cosa è se non è quel
gioco piace un sacco merula o una
fortuna lorenzo l'unica volta che perdo
gobbi che sono condomini strag se vuoi
battere roma in modo migliore farlo
distrarre hai sentito qualcosa farò di
meglio a concentrarvi quali sono i libri
preferiti non rispondere harry potter
ben fatto parliamo del legno delle
bacchette
parliamo del di perché non ci sono più
le mezze stagioni che ti va beh non
stanno neanche male stai andando bene
lorenzo non vincerò mai se continuo a
distrarmi distraiamoci un po invece
marin chiamo la scuola ce l'ho fatta e
hai battuto lorenzo sei stato molto
bravo presso la prima volta che giocavo
biglie me è stato più difficile e te lo
giuro non so come ho fatto
bella partita lorenzo è bravo anche
bravo anche tempo colpa dell'arbitro
nomiche arrivata quella madonna e
fastidio ma che meraviglia cosa vuoi
lurida schifosa maledetta ciao ciao
ostuni vedo che stai meglio di quanto mi
aspettassi dopo lo scontro con il
tranello del diavolo che capelli cia
mentre tutti tra sfollati con le due
piantine io ho fatto qualche ricerca sul
tuo fratello
ma i cazzi tuoi il fratello di ostuni e
non è stato espulso solo per aver messo
in pericolo la scuola in cerca di sale
immaginarie e scomparso subito dopo e in
seguito mi commentano le foto in seguito
si è scoperto che lavorava per voldemort
mio fratello non puoi pronunciare quel
nome di chiamarlo colui che non deve
essere nominato io dico quello che mi
pare piace brava merula così si fa vabbè
ragazzi dire che per ora possiamo
concludere qua è fighissimo c'è nel
senso la trama è veramente [ __ ] ci spero
che vi sia piaciuto come senso che
quando mi piace anche ai social comitato
descrizione se ne sta per scadere e non
ci vediamo al proseguito ragazzi
[Musica]